we're making a pretty big claim we're
making a claim that here we are entering
a second machine age where instead of
overcoming the limitations of our
muscles like we did in the first Machine
Age with the Industrial Revolution with
steam power an electric power and the
internal combustion engine what we're
doing here is overcoming the limitations
of our individual minds in our simple
villa on the outskirts of Bristol lives
dr. grey Walter a neurologist who makes
robots as a hobby just over half a
century ago
robots started exploring the world these
tortoises were built in 1948 and were
among the first electronic autonomous
robots
this model is named LC and she sees out
of a photoelectric cell which rotates
above her body when light strikes the
cell driving and steering mechanism
sends her hurrying towards it
today their successors are almost
infinitely more sophisticated and
they've moved from the lab into the real
world Google's driverless cars have
traveled more than a million miles on
public roads already over the years
there's been no single major
breakthrough instead different
technologies have improved dramatically
sensors machine learning computer vision
and laser scanning who are you they've
created a technology convergence for
advances in robotics or a sweet spot for
a robot revolution
there is no one robotic future something
the result will be mass unemployment and
perhaps the extinction of the human
species
the other future is a cybernetic meadow
where we live free from labor or watched
over by machines of loving grace with
robots boosting our productivity our
social well-being and our health parts
of both those futures are being created
here at the Italian Institute of
Technology basically what we try to do
is to reproduce functionalities that
nature has developed for three billions
years into artificial systems that can
be used to help humans the Walkman robot
looks fearsome and at 120 kilograms with
the power of a superbike it could pack a
punch but it's designed to help humans
in hazardous situations too dangerous
for rescue workers and it was developed
in response to the Fukushima nuclear
disaster
well like ours walkman uses his head to
see the world but this is how he sees it
is rather different but he's using two
cameras which work a bit like eyes to
see what's in front of him but they're
combined with a laser scanner up on top
here which is costly creating a 3d
representation of the environment and
which Walkman is in that ability to
understand the world it's much more
important than its strength or bulk high
icon the iCub may look childlike but
it's smarter more social and it can
learn I am ready to collaborate with you
can you please pass me the chocolate bar
thank you very much we are trying to
making
iCub a good collaborator for humans and
we believe that the key for good
collaboration is the ability of the two
partners of anticipating or predicting
what the other person is gonna do
prosthetics is where some of the most
impressive advances have been made
Daniel Melville was born with one hand
now he's Charlie robotic replacements
I feel more cyborg because it looks
cooler as well and it makes me feel a
lot more confident wearing it open
bionics a UK company is behind this 3d
printed hand it can be custom-built and
fitted in only two days at a cost of two
thousand pounds far cheaper than most
devices we will see children and adults
with completely customized designs hands
in the future that whether they're in
the styles their favorite superhero
their favorite football team it it could
be anything and it could look like
anything it doesn't even have to have
the human shape medicine is already
benefiting from the robot revolution
IBM's Watson is helping clinicians make
cancer diagnosis The Da Vinci Surgical
System helps human surgeons be more
precise and even operate from another
continent robots that tower over the
operating table might themselves
disappear researchers at Imperial
College London have developed
miniaturized robots that work inside the
human body injected into the bloodstream
they allow surgeon to operate on the
cellular level and so at the very
earliest stages of disease the type of
robot we are making actually getting
smaller and smaller can be actually
delivered in the needle form so
therefore you that you don't need to
make incisions so they can actually
follow the curved anatomical pathways
reaching to the side
but improving human life isn't just
about saving it
this robot chef from london-based moley
robotics will go on sale in 2017 it will
automatically prepare more than 2,000
meals at the touch of a smartphone on
today's many crab beasts with the
garnish of tarragon and a drizzle of
olive oil and the entertainment stars of
the future may well be androids Robo
thespian built by a company in Cornwall
took to the stage at the Edinburgh
Fringe Festival this year
that's all a lot of fun until a robot
takes your job as machines get more
skilled they also become more employable
at the expense of humans
it starts with autonomous vehicles
replacing taxi and lorry drivers but
jobs in hospitality accounting and even
law will be at risk to research by
Deloitte predicts that as many as 35
percent of UK jobs could be replaced by
robots others argue that just as the
first Industrial Revolution destroyed
jobs in manual labor but created
entirely new categories of work so too
will robots there will be new human
needs and there will be new jobs that
none of us can predict in advance
already there are people now doing jobs
that nobody envisaged 20 or 30 years ago
and I think they'll be open to people
from with a whole range of abilities but
of course the more we can educate and
train people so they can get into the
high quality jobs the better but I'm not
a pessimist I don't think that we will
all end up unemployed I think actually
we will just be doing different things
and quite possibly more rewarding things
but there is no guarantee that this
second Industrial Revolution will follow
the same rule
Tech Progress is the only free lunch out
there it is making our pie bigger
translation it's making us in aggregate
a great deal better off a great deal
wealthier now the challenge is that
there is no economic law that says that
as that pie grows it's going to be
divided up in a quote fair way or
divided up the same way that it was five
years ago ten years ago but maybe the
whole robot revolution makes the very
concept of a job rather old-fashioned
what is so big and important about
having a job the whole way that the
system works is that you have to have a
job to get money to buy food to live I
think we're going to have to change that
we're going to have to break out of that
and force a really having a job is not
important it's best if you don't have a
job enjoy yourselves and we need to move
towards that let the technology do the
work why do humans have to have jobs
economic questions are pressing but so
are ethical ones robotic systems are
being used more and more in warfare is
it really right to delegate the decision
to kill a human to a machine that's a
very strong moral argument in my view
but my biggest concern now that I'm more
mature in the field is really about
global security United States is very
much pushing the technology and so now
what they want to do is to try to get at
the military advantage again get an edge
by having these autonomous weapons
that's weapons that can go out and
select their own target and kill them
without any human involvement but what
they're not thinking about and it's very
very blinkered because what happens when
everybody has them
if the near term is complicated the long
term future is the will during the
robert revolution is happening right now
i believe it's really in its early days
and the phrase i always use when i think
about what's going on is we ain't seen
nothing yet
the advances that have come so far these
are not the crowning achievements of the
second Machine Age these are the warm-up
acts and the really interesting stuff is
yet to come
robots right now I like smart phones
loaded with apps very clever a dedicated
tasks but not very adaptable this icon
here has legs and it can balance you can
even give it a little shove sorry and
I'll stay on its own two feet that so
can be more mobile in the world and
robots are going to become a bigger part
of all our lives they're also going to
keep getting more intelligent one day
they might be as smart as ours and after
that they could be even smarter they may
not always be as friendly as this guy
here one goal of researchers is to build
a general artificial intelligence much
more like the human mind if we one day
develop machines that are superior to us
in general intelligence then this
machine super intelligence might be in a
very strong position to shape the future
according to its preferences and
hopefully those preferences will be
aligned with ours and it would be a
great win but but that's basically what
I think it will eventually be a big deal
it could be something as important as
the rise of Homo sapiens if one is
thinking about the long-term prospects
for for Humanity or life on this planet
and machine super intelligence does seem
to be one of the major if not the most
important event that will occur at some
points
superintelligence is sometimes called
the singularity its evangelist believed
that super intelligent benevolent
machines will erase poverty and
injustice as a stroke and allow us to
live forever by coming up with
innovations we can't even dream of
others warned that super intelligence
could be humanity's last invention and
according to a Sky News survey 40
percent of us fear that robots could
eventually wipe out humans super
intelligence is a long way off if indeed
it is feasible but this isn't a robotic
future it's happening right now
Tom Cheshire Sky News